نوصل اقتصاديا ومن الجانب الاقتصادي
تحديدا في زمن تصريحات من وظائف
التكنولوجيا يبقى هناك اناس في امان من
هؤلاء هم الحرفيون والعمال المهره
بريطانيا مثلا التي تشهد ازمه اقتصاديه
كشفت ارقام من كونفدراليه العمل والتوظيف
ان عجله الانتاج مهدده بسبب الشهور ملايين
الوظائف من العمال في قطاعات مختلفه
واستدعوات لتسهيل هجره اليد العامله الى
بريطانيا الدنمارك ايضا اعلنت عن قائمه
وظائف جديده لشغل الاف الوظائف وفتحت باب
تاشيرات والهجره للحراثيين بينما في
المانيا كشفت اتحاد اصحاب المهن الحره ان
نقصى العمال المهارات السبب في مشكلات لدى
العديد من من يعملون لحصابهم الخاصه دعونا
اولا نتابع قصه من زاويه عربيه وبالتحديد
من الاردن
في زمن الازمات الاقتصاديه لن تكون في
مامن حتى وان كنت خلف مكتبك في العمل اكثر
من حرفيا يتقن مهنته اليدويه كانت جار او
حلاق او حتى عامل بناء
[موسيقى]
نحن لا نتحدث بالضروره عن دول الغرب حيث
موجات الاقالات في شركات التكنولوجيا
مثل الاردن حيث للمهن الحرفيه لا تتوافر
في غيرها مثل حريات ساعات العمل وعدم
احتياجها الى راس مال كبير وملاءمتها لذوي
الدراسه المحدوده
[موسيقى]
والاهم من ذلك العوائد السريعه والمزيه
فبحسب الارقام يتراوح متوسط الاجور في
مهنه السباكه ما بين 620 دينارا شهريا
وتصل الى 920 دينارا شهريا مقارنه بخريجه
هندسه يتقاضى 300 الى 400 دينار شهريا
وفي امريكا والدول المتقدمه نجد نوعا
مميزا من الرعايه لهذه المهن حيث اصبحت
السباكه في المرتبه الثانيه ضمن افضل مهن
المقاولات هناك وفي المرتبه الخامسه كافضل
مهنه دون تعليم اما من ناحيه الدخل فهي في
المرتبه التاسعه كافضل الوظيفه تضر دخلا
دون درجه علميه جامعيه
في ما يصلوا اجر السباك من ساعات العمل
الاضافيه فقط الى 200 الف دولار سنويا
اضافه الى راتبه الثابت الذي يصل الى 90
الف دولار سنويا
[موسيقى]
دائما في الستوديو جميله سمر المشتى
الصحفيه في قسم الاقتصادي يسعد صباحك اهلا
بكرح الموظفين هذه الفعل يمكن القول ان
المهن الحرفيه باتت البديل الافضل اليوم
في زمن الازمات الاقتصاديه والماليه
يعني على سبيل المثال وصرح 18000 اليوم
البنوك ايضا بلشت بالتسريح بسبب بوادر
الازمه الماليه يمكن
اخرى اعلن عن تسريحه اكثر من ثلاثه اهداف
فبالفعل هناك همم تسريحات كبيره في القطاع
المهن الاخرى الان بالنسبه للمهن الحرفيه
هي اشياء دائما نحتاجها يعني دائما انت
تحتاجين سباك دائما تحتاجين كهربجي
فيعتمد ايضا باي مكان بالفعل خصوصا في
الاردن انا اهلي عايشين في الاردن كان
يجينا سباك بالاول قبل سنتين كان ياخذ على
الانسبكشن او الزياره 10 دنانير ما يعادل
تقريبا 50 درهم او 50 ريال اليوم ياخذ دبل
بالضبط بعد سنتين 20 وحتى تشوفين شايل
شنطه مثل الدكتور ومرتب ولابسه كذا مش ال
الفكره اللي في بالنا وطبعا في اوروبا هذا
الشيء بعد اكثر يعني هناك مش واحد صلح
للشيخ خلص صار سباك او صار كهربجي هناك في
شهادات ومعتمده ما يقدر يشتغل
تدريب ودراسه ومعاهد متخصصه ونقابات تخصصه
تحميهم وفي بنج معين للاجور خصوصا في
اوروبا مثل ما قلنا يمكن البارحه كنا
نتكلم في نيويورك او اوروبا البنيه
التحتيه متقدمه يعني كلها همم كلها بنايات
قديمه تحتاج الى الكثير من الصيانه
ازدهرت وايضا من الاشياء اللي اثرت على
اعمالهم وعلامات خولهم ورواتبهم انه زادت
طلب عليهم خصوصا في فتره كرونه فما بعد
لانه احجم الكثير منهم عن العوده الى سوق
العمل لما كانوا ياخذون المعونات سواء
باوروبا او المعونات الحكوميه او بامريكا
فيقول لك خلص انا اقعد في البيت اشتغل
يعني في بريطانيا ذكرتوها بالتقرير وصل
الامر الى الاستعانه بالسجناء
لقصابين في في الملاحم الدجاج والخرفان
والى اخره فكان الامر بهذا السوء انه كان
هناك نقص لدى زادت اجورهم بعد اكثر من
السنوات اللي قبل طب سمر سالنا ان الناس
خصوصا في مصر ما هي الحرفه التي لم تختفي
برايت نسمعهم ونرجع
[موسيقى]
في حرف كثير مثلا زي النجاره تمام
ومن ايام سيدنا نوح يعني تقريبا قصه
السفينه دي اللي تذكرتها يعني دلوقتي
سيدنا نوح المنسوجات التطريز الحاجات اللي
هي التراث بتاعنا مثلا ممكن
حاجه زي النجاره مثلا
زي النقاشه دي الحرف اللي هم ما تنكرتش
ابدا في مصر عندنا
الانسان يد الانسان هي اللي بتصنع
موظف حكومه
دلوقت اي حد ممكن
[موسيقى]
في الجواز في الفرح كده لازم يتصوروا
الحلاق والكوافير وبتمد لدين وحاجه
الوحيده اللي عمرها ما تنقرض حتى ما فيش
حد عمره هيبطل يحلق طبعا
[موسيقى]
طيب سمر رغم انه الحرفيين ليحصلون على
ميزات الموظف في القطعه العامه والخاص من
تامين مثلا الا انهم في خصوصا في الخارج
سمعنا ارقام خياليه يحصل عليها اصحاب
المهن ك- عمر الصيانه وما الى ذلك هل هذا
فعلا ما يحصل هلا بالنسبه للتامين
والمميزات الاخرى يعتمد اذا في الخارج
هناك مثل ما قلنا نقابات المناظمه اكثر
لاعمالهم وفي تامين وفي اشياء اخرى غير عن
العلم العربي بس بالفعل خصوصا لان جبت
مجموعه من المهن من اكثر شيعه خذ الى اخر
همم الى اقل شيء عندك اللي يسوي الصيانه
للالفيتر للمصعد هذا ياخذ تقريبا من متوسط
88,000 دولار سنويا اضف اليها اللبس اللي
قد تتجاوز ال 20,000 دولار سنويا اللي
يسوي المصعد طبعا هاي واحده من اهم الامور
اذا خرب المصعد في مشكله عندك اللي راديش
انسرق بس اللي هي معالجه
الاشعه بالنسبه لامراض السرطان ايضا لانه
تتعرض لمخاطر كبيره ايضا من اعلى الرواتب
اللي هي ايضا تتجاوز ال 85,000 اضافه الى
التفسير اللي تحصل عليها عندك
مساعد لطبيب الاسنان ايضا اتكلم اكثر في
الخارج هذه المهنه ولهذا اليوم ينطوهم همم
اقامات مباشره في اوروبا ويطلبون في
اوروبا يمكن اكثر من مهن اخرى مهندس او
طبيب او الى اخره لانهم بحاجه اليهم عده
ايضا همم الالكترونيشن وهو الكهربجي احنا
نسميه وعندك طبعا المسؤول الانسبكتور او
المفتش على عمليه البناء ايضا من اعلى
الرواتب خصوصا في اوروبا وامريكا طيب
سؤالنا اللي كانت تفائل شو المهنه الحرفيه
اللي لا يمكن الاستغناء عنها باعتقادك
اقتصاديه همم سمر والله يتهيا لي يعني
كلها مهمه مثل ما يمكن السباق يمكن
السماعات امشي لانه واحد يعني بالنهايه
يمكن احنا بنحب نشتغل بايدنا فاهم انا
بالنسبه لي يمكن السبت
معلقين على الحرفه التي تحدث عنها في
قصتنا من الشارع اليوم حرفتك مستقبلك
مبادره انشاها حلاق مصري اللي يشجع الشباب
على التعلم حرفته املا في ان يكون له دور
وموساهما في القضاء على البطاله وحمايه
الحرف من تسعه محمود قرر ان يخصص يوما كل
اسبوع يعلم فيه المقبلين على حرفته
الحلاقه مجانا ثم بدات المبادره في
الانتشار فاقدم ممتهنوا حرف اخرى على
التعليمي حرفه ايضا في الصوره جميله
للتكاتف الاجتماعي بمصر
[موسيقى]
انت منين من القاهره
يوم كتبها وسام اكيد ندى حديثينا عن محمود
وعرفينا شو بصير اهتمامه بحرفه الحلاقه
اتفضلي يا ندى
صباح الخير يا سهام احنا دلوقتي معانا
الاستاذ محمود مؤسس المبادره بس قبل اي
حاجه انا بجد المبادره دي انا حسيت فيها
بالمعنى الحقيقي للتكاته في الاجتماعي في
ظل اي ظرف صعب ممكن يكون بيمر به العالم
كله ان اا يتم تخصيص يوم معين علشان يعلم
الشباب الحرف ده لا علاقه انتشار واسع جدا
جدا همم في المحافظه فوق ما انت ممكن
تتخيلي ده يكلمني اكثر عنه الاستاذ محمود
صباح الخير صباح الخير يا فندم
همم الحمد لله رب العالمين انا انسان بسيط
مؤمن بدوري بالمشاركه الشعبيه الفعاله
بسبب تواجدي على الارض ك- صاحب محل حلاقه
فبتعامل مع كل فئات الشعب وكل الاقمار
الصينيه ومحل الحلاقه دوت بيبقى اي مكان
للفضفضه واللي عنده مشكله بيحب يقولها عند
الحلاق ويتكلم معه وانا من النوع اللي
بيحب يسمع في وقت الناس ما بتسمعش فيه
يعني كل عاوز يتكلم انا باسمع الانسان
وبيعهم بيشتكوا عايزين يتعلموا حاجه
طبعا في زر الظروف اللي احنا بنمر بيها
ال- العالم كله يعني فالناس كلها ال- ال-
ال- اللي بيتكلم في
البطوله الاسعار الغاليه اللي عاوز يزود
داخله فالمشاكل ديت كلها في الشباب في
الاقمار الصناعيه كلها فانا باتكلم معهم
الحمد لله في اي مش مشكله وكده حتى عشان
كده صموا المحل بتاعي الصالون الشعبي ال-
همم خدمه المواطنين الحمد لله رب العالمين
تخش فيه قال لي احنا جربنا ودخلنا
اكاديميات وكده كثير وكانت بمبالغ عاليه
وفي الاخر ما بيتعلمش سنه ولا حاجه بياخذ
شهاده بس اكثر
همم عندي همم قلت ابدا برده بنفسي يعني
اللي يجيء يتدرب عندي يطلع صنيه شاطر ادي
له كل خبايا الصنعه مش ابخل عليه باي حاجه
انا مش جاي همم نظره ادي له لا انا هاضربه
عملي ومن هنا بقى قلت ايه يعني هيطلع من
عندي وانا اللي هاجي له سوق العمل هي مش
العمليه مش نظريه بس وفي ناس علمتهم
واشتغلوا معك بعد كده
من اول دوره الحمد لله رب العالمين كان
العدد 10 او 12 فرد عشان كده حتى انا ايه
قلت ادرب كنت كان يوم في الاسبوع بس اضرب
واحد او اثنين في المحل لقيت الموضوع برده
زاد وكده طبعا المحل هيبقى زحمه مش هنعرف
نشتغل فيه فكان في سنتر جنب المحل يعني
بعد مني كده فقلت ايه اجر المكان منه همم
زيت رحت السنتر فقلت الراجل عاوز يتاجر
المكان فروحت هاجر المكان منه وبيتاتي
الدوره هناك فلم عربي
مجانيه
بجد فلما اعرف هو الراجل برده ايه شارك
معنا فلوس وكده والحمد لله اول دوره همم
وجهنا للخريجين كلهم م- من الدوره لسوق
العمل ومن ضمنهم شاب اشتغل معي انا شخصيا
في المحل الحمد لله ولو كان باب رزقوا
عندي الحمد لله رب العالمين
دورات مجانيه مثل ما يقول محمود معانا سمر
صباح الخير يا سمر صباح الخير ندى هل
تكفيه لمحمود
اللي ياتي من مهنه همم الحلاقه للمعيشه
اليوميه يعني
كم ولا كيف ولا لا
نسالكم
كم مصدر للرزق
هي سمر في الاستوديو بتسالك هل الدخل اللي
بيدخل لك من حرفه زي الحلاقه كافي للمعيشه
اليوميه الحمد لله رب العالمين
الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني لا الحمد لله
كيف طبعا زي الفل انا راجل برده متزوج
وفاتح مين وعندي اولاد الحمد لله الصنعه
ديت همم الحمد لله كل المدربين معنا
لتعليم الحرف كلهم مؤهلات عشان لما شاب
يقول لك لا انا هاشتغل ليه بسمعه لا كل
المدربين يعني هي الحمد لله ما همم ما
اشتغلتش لا الحرف دي هي اللي جوزتني وهي
الحمد لله رب العالمين همم مخليه زي الفل
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الى جانب كل مهنه لازم يكون عندنا شيء
عمله سايد انا انا شخصيا اصلح كراسي
الحديقه جدا شاطره بهذا الموضوع
بالفعل هي صنعه ومهنه حرفيه ستبقى معنا
مستقبلا بالتاكيد وقت زمن
واضافه الى انها تسكرت انه احنا كلنا
تعلمنا نسوي يعني انا زوجي صار لي سنتين
انا احلق له في البيت
واحده من الاشياء انه اثرت على النمو ما
راح ترجع مثل مستويات 2019 الى احد همم
نهايه السنه القادمه 24 اليوم هذا القطاع
هو يمثل يعني صناعه الحلاقه 215 مليار
دولار واين موبي نحو سبعه في المئه سنويا
البارحه اتصلت باحدى الشركه اللي هي تبيعه
وتشتري البزنسز الصالونات اسمها بزنس اكس
اكس
لازم ينتبه اليها اللي يفتح صالون او اللي
يريد يفتح صالون حتى يكون صالونه ناجح
اللي هو اهم شيء اولا الموقع وتوافر
الباكينج عادي اهم شيء ثاني شيء الحلاق
دائما ياخذ زباينه فلازم انت كمديره مشروع
او صاحبه المشروع انه تعتني بهذا الحلاق
اللي جاي عندك وجايب زباينه لانه بالنهايه
زباين راح يلحقونا الحلاق ايضا مساله
اللويه التي بوينتس مهمه جدا ومساله
القدره للحجز عبر التطبيق ترينج جديد ايضا
في مهنه الحلاقه اللي هي القدوم الى
المنزل وتقديم الخدمات الى المنزل هذا
يظهر ويلاقي رواج كبير خصوصا في المنطقه
ما عن نزول المراه اكثر الى سوق العمل
شكرا